true or false based in reality or not
you create your belief systems from
those belief systems we create our life
and then we go well yeah but that's the
way life is that's the reality of my
life and it's the reality of Our Lives
because we believed those things that
were instilled in us before we had
reasoning
to work through them so you know how
much you love that dog oh God when I
walked in the house Blanche okay so just
feel that in your heart just feel how
much you love little blends
it's funny because it makes me like oh
right when you said that it kind of
brings up like motions yeah yeah to give
that to yourself
see it really is easy